-Welcome, everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
We're gonna get to everything
that's going on
in the country right now.
Last night, there were a lot
of peaceful protests
around the country,
more peaceful
than other nights, so,
that's a step
in the right direction.
Also today, all four
police officers were charged
in the murder
of George Floyd, so,
here's hoping for some
justice for that family.
And there's many more families
that deserve justice as well,
but, again, these are all steps
in the right direction.
My guest tonights are --
Senator Kamala Harris.
We also have Talib Kweli,
who is a rapper and activist
and we get to catch up.
We've known each other
for a long time.
And we also get to hear
from comedian Roy Wood Jr.
It's gonna be a fun show.
Let's get to some news,
here, you guys.
After nine days of protests,
a new poll found
that pretty much everyone thinks
President Trump
is not doing a good job.
Check it out.
-Right now,
based on the data we have,
the public is not
with this president.
His approval rating
continues to be terrible --
54% disapproval,
the highest ever for a president
at this point in his first term.
-Yeah, not good.
Even worse for Trump,
that poll was taken
among his kids.
Right now, Trump seems
to be polling somewhere
between Jake, Paul,
and that time I decide to grow
a mustache for the summer.
-[ Laughing ]
-Honey.
You liked it.
-I did. I liked it.
I was the one.
[ Laughing ]
-Ohhh.
My heavens.
There's gotta be someone else.
No, probably not.
-Mnh-mnh.
-[ Chuckling ]
When Trump saw his numbers,
he started crying
and then, he was like...
[ As Trump ] "I'm not crying.
It's the tear gas
from my church photo shoot
blowing back in my face.
That's right, everyone seems
to be turning on him.
To give you an example,
"Fox & Friends"
is now just "Fox & Friend."
You know, at this point,
Trump should just go
for 100% disapproval
and then take credit
for uniting the country.
-[ Laughs ]
-But Trump's thinking can --
Trump's thinking he
can turn this around.
Tomorrow, he's gonna walk
to the Vatican,
hold up a Bible, and like...
[ As Trump ]
Okay, Pope Francis,
now let's do a silly one.
Speaking of that,
how does Trump not know
how to hold a book?
I've never seen anyone hold --
This is --
Have you ever seen anyone
hold anything like that?
It's like a --
It's like a broken
G.I. Joe hand or something.
I've never -- It's like
he's plucking the Bible
from the Bible tree.
I've never seen anyone hold --
[ Laughing ] Have you ever
seen anyone told, anyone?
Honey, have you read this?
Does anyone want to read this?
[ Chuckle ]
Can I have another --
Can I have another
glass of water?
Sure. Alright. You could
put your hand down, now,
on the cup.
Okay.
-[ Laughing ]
-Meanwhile, former
President George W. Bush
released a statement
that some people think
is a shot at Trump.
He wrote, "Those who set out
to silence those voices
do not understand
the meaning of America --
or how it becomes
a better place."
You know, it's serious
if they got George W. Bush
to write words.
Even televangelist Pat Robertson
called out Donald Trump for his
response to the protests.
This is pretty amazing.
Watch this.
-He said, "I'm ready to send
in military troops,
if the nation's governors don't
act to quell the violence."
He spoke of them as being jerks.
You just don't do that,
Mr. President!
It isn't cool!
-Yeah. Yeah.
He was like, "This isn't cool!
P.Rob's out!
Microphone drop."
You know we live in crazy times
when we're all agreeing
with the guy who once said that
[ Laughing ]
gay people cause hurricanes.
And, as more of the country
turns on Trump,
Republican senators
still have very little to say.
Take a look at this.
-Senator McConnell,
was what the president
did last night
the right thing to do?
Was what the president
did last night right?
Senator Enzi.
Are you concerned at all
about what happened
at the White House last night?
-He was actually asked the same
question after leaving lunch.
He was like,
"Uh...I'm late for dinner."
Well, you may remember
last week,
Trump was rushed
to the White House bunker
for an hour
because of the protests.
Well, earlier today,
Trump said the report was false.
Take a listen.
-Well, it was a false report.
I wasn't down.
I went down during the day
and I was there for a tiny,
little, short period of time
and it was much more
for an inspection.
-Yeah, it's kinda like
running into a friend at a CVS
when you're buying
hemorrhoid cream.
You're like, "I'm not buying.
I'm just inspecting.
What is this?
Hemorrhoid cream?
I'm just inspecting.
I'm a hemorrhoid
cream inspector.
What's the big deal?
I don't want that."
And, finally,
after a rough few days,
here's something to bring us up.
-So, we're gonna start
manufacturing doses
of the vaccines.
-And here's something
to bring us back down.
-But if it acts
like other common virus,
common coronaviruses,
it likely is not gonna be
a very, very long
duration of immunity.
-[ Snaps fingers ]
Ah!
Guys, Senator Kamala Harris
is a senator
from the great state
of California.
I got to talk to her today.
Here is my chat
with Senator Kamala Harris.
Senator Harris,
thank you so much
for being on "The Tonight Show"
and coming back to us.
-Thanks.
-I know these are
very difficult times
and you're very,
very busy right now,
so I really, really
appreciate this. Thank you.
Thank you so much for this.
-Good to be with you again.
-If you don't mind,
I'd like to get right to --
the breaking news today
was that
the three
other officers involved
with the death of George Floyd
have now been charged.
What are your thoughts?
-As of today, we're one
step closer to justice.
But, you know,
I have long believed
and I think we all know,
"Justice delayed
is justice denied."
And why it has to take so long
for those other three officers
to be held accountable.
It has, you know, caused pain
for Mr. Floyd's family
and the community
and all of us
who watched that video
and are watching
what's happening.
But, thankfully, Keith Ellison,
the attorney general,
has taken over the case and is
obviously not wasting any time
in making sure that justice is
delivered to Mr. Floyd's family
and to that community
and to our country.
-What are your thoughts on the
administration currently
and how they've been dealing
with this,
on top of the pandemic?
-I mean, Jimmy,
we've got a president
of the United States,
or, at least, somebody
who occupies that position,
who doesn't understand the job
and isn't capable
of performing the job.
And, most recently,
you know, frankly,
the words that he speaks are
the words, not of a president.
They're the words of a dictator.
I was in D.C. that night.
You know, I joined
the protesters in D.C.
-I saw that.
-So I've been out there,
you know, and I will tell you
that, had my parents
not marched and shouted
in the '60s,
I would not have been,
together with all those who did,
I'm pretty certain that I would
not be talking with you tonight
as only the second Black woman
ever elected to the
United States Senate.
There are so many things
that we, as a society,
have benefited from because
people took to the streets
to exercise their
First Amendment right
to speak out
and speak to their government
so that we could see progress.
And the idea that,
just a couple of nights ago,
this guy, Donald Trump,
who happens to, right now,
be president
of the United States,
would throw tear gas at people
who are peacefully protesting
-Oof!
-so he could clear the roads!
Right? It reminds me
of the emperor with no clothes.
So he could clear the roads,
to walk!
To carry the Bible,
the Holy Bible.
You know, it is as though
it were one of his steaks,
one of his Trump steaks...
-[ Laughs ]
-...for a photo op.
And, that night, 'cause I was
at my apartment in D.C.,
I heard the Black Hawks flying.
You know, the last time
I was on a Black Hawk?
When I was in Afghanistan.
-Wow!
-These are military aircraft
that are being turned
on the people of America.
He's talking about turning
the U.S. military
on its own people.
I serve on the Senate
Intelligence Committee.
I serve on the
Homeland Security Committee.
This is not the America
that people fought for
and this is not the America that
is the America of our ideals.
This is something altogether,
and that's why people
are marching and shouting.
And the optimism that I have
is the optimism
that all of us have
whenever we are
in these kinds of fights,
which is it's not a fight
against something.
It's fight for something.
But, you know...
-Wow.
-...Donald Trump doesn't get it
and that's why everyone's
gotta make sure
that we vote in November
and show ourselves and the world
that we are better than this.
-Speaking of November...
-Mm-hmm.
-...I've seen you in
numerous interviews,
saying that
it's gonna be
a very important time
in our history.
-Uh-huh.
Yes, it will be.
-What are we looking at, here,
in November, coming up?
-Okay, so, first of all,
there's so much at stake
in the election.
I mean, so, again,
we're in the midst
of a public health --
we're in a pandemic.
We have had over 100,000 souls,
in just less than 100 days,
perish, die, right?
Millions of people
have contracted this virus
and are suffering in its grip.
We have over 40 million people
who were working,
who are now unemployed,
just in the last 100 days,
because of this pandemic.
And one of the things that --
One, I will again say that
we would not be in as bad
of a situation as we are,
had the president
not taken immediate action,
not called it a hoax
and minimized
the seriousness of it.
And we are where we are.
So, in terms of the election,
one of the things
that we have to make sure
is that people can go
and vote and be safe.
So, I have a proposal.
I call it the Vote Safe Act,
that basically is
that states should have --
all states should have
vote by mail.
All states should
have early voting,
at least 20 days
before Election Day,
so you can figure out when
it works for you to go vote.
And all states should also,
for people who do go
to the polls,
have safety precautions,
things like curbside voting,
or put in place wait times,
so that, unlike in Wisconsin,
people stood in line
for two to three hours,
people would only have
to stand in line
for a certain number of minutes.
So, these are some of the things
that I'm fighting for.
In terms of this BS about fraud,
listen, Donald Trump spoke
the quiet words out loud
when he said
that he was concerned that he
and the Republican Party
would lose,
if people vote by mail.
Meanwhile, he himself, and I
believe family members of him,
have voted by mail consistently.
So, the whole thing about fraud
in the vote-by-mail system
is really a red herring
to distract people
from the seriousness
of this moment,
which is that we're
in the middle of a pandemic.
We want people to be able
to be safe when they vote
and we definitely
wanna make sure
that people don't have
to make a choice
between their health and their
right to exercise their voice,
especially at this moment
in time in our country.